Good morning, Hank. It's Sunday.
Yesterday, I was at the Indiana State Fair,
and I got to see the world's largest boar.
He weighs more than eleven hundred pounds,
and he can't stand up because
his body is too big for his tiny, little legs.
And what, you ask, is the name of the world's
largest boar?
Walkin' Tall.
Get it? It's funny. Because he can't walk.
Hank, Walkin' Tall - the world's largest boar,
who can't walk - reminded me a
little bit of America's healthcare system.
Depending on your perspective, he's either
impressively huge, or ...
distressingly huge.
[Music]
So, what do you do when you have a pig that's
so big he can't walk?
You either kill him, put him on a diet, or
keep feedin' him,
which is more or less what the healthcare
debate boils down to.
So, Hank, I want to talk in a nonpartisan
way about the healthcare debate, but
I don't want to scream,
and I don't want to act like the people watching
us have the intellectual
sophistication of braindamaged goldfish,
and, mostly, I don't wanna talk about death
panels because they're not in the bill,
and the stupid, unsophisticated debate
about them has distracted
from a really large and significant issue.
Okay, Hank, so here are two things that pretty
much everyone conservative or liberal
agrees upon:
one, the United States spends way too much
of its gross domestic product
on healthcare;
and two, our current healthcare system is
radically unfair.
I'm not saying that other models wouldn't
be more unfair, just that our current one
is unfair.
Whether you have good healthcare in America
is dependent largely on
whether you work for a big company
(because big companies have to provide health benefits),
and second, whether you have a pre-existing
condition,
which a lot of times isn't your fault.
Some people argue that we need a sort of large-scale, government-run
insurance company,
the so-called "Public Option",
which everyone would be able to buy into,
and poorer people would pay less
than richer people,
and then this huge, government-run insurer
would negotiate lower costs for procedures
and also cut down on the number
of procedures used.
Now, even though the Public Option would not
in any way eliminate private insurers,
private insurers still hate the Public Option
because they know that the
government-run insurance company will be larger
and, therefore, more able
to negotiate lower prices,
which will, in turn, make the public insurance
less expensive,
which will make people less inclined to use private insurance.
Then, you have people who want to put the
pigs on a diet, who say that
instead of a public option, we can create
these sort of non-profit insurance
companies that will then have to compete with
private insurance,
and, because they won't be for-profit companies, they'll be incentivized
not to work for the shareholders in the company,
but instead to work for the patients they represent.
Now, of course, the downside of the put-the-pig-on-the-diet plan is that you still end up with
tens of millions of people
who have no health insurance whatsoever.
And then, there are the people who don't
want a healthcare system overhaul.
They want to keep feeding the pig.
A lot of those people are happy with the current
state of their healthcare and,
to be frank, I think they probably don't want
to pay for people who make
stupid decisions.
And on some level, Hank, I can empathize
with this,
because when I was at the Indiana State Fair, and I saw chocolate-covered bacon,
I thought to myself:
"Geez! I don't really want to be on the financial
hook for people who eat
chocolate-covered bacon."
So, Hank, here's the underlying problem:
even though a lot of people are screaming,
"I don't want socialism! No socialism!"
in America right now, we have a lot of socialism.
We share the cost of schools, and roads, and
the military.
We also currently have socialized medicine;
we just have an outrageously
bloated and inefficient system of socialized
medicine,
because there are hospitals in America where
anyone can go and get treatment.
That treatment may eventually bankrupt you,
and it may be of poor quality,
but you can get it,
and I would argue that it is the inefficiency
of our socialized medicine that, in the end,
makes healthcare so much more
expensive than it is anywhere else in the world.
Is healthcare a privilege, or is it a right?
If it's a privilege (even if it's a really desirable privilege, like indoor plumbing),
we need to stop giving healthcare of any kind to uninsured people
who can't pay for it in advance.
But Hank, I have to tell you, I think the reason we continue to treat people who are uninsured
is because we don't believe that healthcare is a privilege.
We believe that it is a right.
And if it is a right - like life, liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness -
it is the responsibility of a government to protect
that right.
I'll see you on Tuesday [DFTBA].